salut à tous ces cas madame et je serai
dans le film les profs le 17 avril
prochain
ça va être très très cool gelé devant
moi vous vous l'aurez bientôt devant
vous à cette occasion on a décidé de
lancer un grand concours avec toute
l'équipe du film
ça va s'appeler la battle des classes le
concept il est très simple prenez votre
classe vous demander à tout le monde de
participer vos parents vos profs votre
famille votre chien votre poney ce que
vous voulez et après vous vous inscrivez
sur la page facebook du film
les profs à la fin la classe qui aura
gagné le plus de points mais je peux
vous jurer qu'on vous faire un gros gros
gros cadeau fin sera pas moi
personnellement mais ce sera
certainement la production du film des
profs qui vous feront un très très gros
cadeau hier on compte sur vous j'ai
[ __ ] la console